governor's emergency order number 12 and
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
to the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on the
bills referred to the committee
today we are not executing anything
today
this uh this public hearing
okay please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming that
all the members of the committee and
selective legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to this
contemporariously
listen and if necessary participate in
the meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting shall call 271
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
and please also state whether there is
anybody in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
all right you're on all right good
morning everyone
uh call the roll uh representative hunt
i am here and i am alone okay
representative patusik i am here
upstairs but my wife is downstairs
hey representative osborne
representative amman here and alone
representative hamm ear alone
representative de palma you're in alone
representative greeson president alone
representative terry i'm here all by
myself
representative bartlett i'm here alone
in this room
representative abel present and alone
representative van gaalton present and
alone
it looks like representative herbert's
here but not as muted
okay yeah yes well he's yeah
there you go okay yeah i'm here okay
all right and representative fargo
i'm here and i'm alone representative
weston here and alone
representative bill you here
hold on representative burroughs
i'm here alone but my husband may come
back during the hearing at some point
okay and last representative mccleary
i'm here in the loan
all right mr chair that's 17 present
excellent
all right we'll open up the public
hearing on senate bill 138 and hear
from senator waters the prime sponsor
good morning
senator good morning mr chairman members
of the committee it's good to see you
all i'm
senator david waters from district 4 to
introduce
senate bill 138 just a little bit of
background that's
this bill was originally on another
subject
and an issue came before me from a
constituent who may hear from
about an issue dealing with investment
medals
contracts so we had a hearing on an
amendment in
senate commerce and that amendment ended
up replacing
all of the underlying bills so that's
how it comes to you
today it came out of that the senate
comments five to zero and off the senate
for
24 to zero so what this bill does
is um it addresses an issue that has
arisen for
people in new hampshire who wish to take
part
in the trade of investment metals and
investment gems
and um what made this difficult for new
hampshire folks
is that existing statute rsa421b1-102
32b3 says that the physical delivery of
metals must be made within 20 days to a
person
or as a designated bank or licensed
broker dealer
only within new hampshire and this
created a lot of problems for the folks
who want to trade in this who might be
doing two-party trades back and forth
with the person from whom they bought
the
bought the medals and uh so they would
have to pay for shipment insurance and
postal costs and also delay
in their ability to make their their
trades
so i'm 15 others 15 other states have
done this
um and in terms of developing the
language
um here i wanted to make sure that we
maintain new hampshire's strong consumer
protection laws
while also respecting the right
of new hampshire residents to
participate in markets they want to
participate
in we had a great deal of assistance
from barry glennon of the new hampshire
bureau of securities regulations who
made some suggestions that we needed to
have some more definitions of um
depository here
and to uh make sure we had an
appropriate
number of days for the delivery
and with that uh he supported the bill
and um and we put in the in the bill
the language that he thought that that
we needed
um so to conclude um mr chairman i i
think that
what the bill does is it balances
consumer protection
provides new hampshire's with
opportunity to better dissipate uh
in these markets and um i'd be happy to
take any questions you have
um yeah so i don't it's barry i don't
see
barry coming on so the only thing
that uh that piqued my interest was um
this is in the uniform securities act
and generally and i noticed maybe not
you can't really answer this question so
but uh generally the securities uh
uniform acts
are you know there's a com entity in
chicago that comes out with these
uniform
statutes and they're all uniform so um
i hear you saying that this language is
in other
states but it's not actually promoted by
the
that entity in chicago or the uniform
commercial dinner for
the you know we're inserting it into our
security attack are you familiar with
this at all
yeah somewhat uh thank you mr chairman
um you know
the the original regulations were
adopted back in 1985
and boy a whole lot has changed in all
kinds of uh training and markets
since that time and um of course
the uniformed securities act allows
states to make its own regulations
which all states do to ensure um
consumer protection ought to recognize
the particularities there but
in this case um so much has changed in
the trading of precious
metals assuming investment metals that
um
you know states have said look we've got
to we've got to make it possible for our
residents to
you know i mean i believe strong in free
markets and um you know our residents
should be able to participate in this
and this is
you know a very a relatively minor fix
to our state statute that then
enables people to do that um i have i'm
not aware of
any um objection um
based on the uh national act and um
you know the other states that have gone
down this this road um
you know have done this for several
years so i think it's a good way for us
to go
for new hampshire of new hampshire folks
okay we do have questions now
representative mclaren
um thank you uh mr chairman so my
understanding is that this would
allow me to hold the middle contracts
uh actual gold and silver and whatever
uh with that
in my ira with somebody that possesses
it physically
out of state so they don't have to be in
new hampshire correct
right so they have to be shipped um now
of course you have to have
all the appropriate documentation and
protections that you've they've
been delivered to an innocent to a
depository of your choice and so on and
so forth
but they don't have to be in new
hampshire and that was the bottleneck
that you had to get them here and that
meant you had to have a relationship
with the bank
uh and this and that the other thing and
then if you're making
trades quickly um that sure
makes it difficult for you so i've
already done this i hope i'm
not subject to arrest
well me too uh representative thank you
for your question
would you believe representative johnson
has a question
thank you thank you for taking my
question my question is you had
mentioned
something about in the
bill it says seven day period but did
you
said something about a 20-day period can
you elaborate because you kind of lost
me
on that i think thanks for the question
i'm sorry i just
you know jumbled over that um originally
we had the
the the 21 days and um
barry glennon said uh he thought it'd be
much more appropriate to have seven days
and um that made sense so that's why we
changed it to seven here
so you shortened up the number of days
and you
want to make which to me doesn't make a
lot of sense because if you're
you're wanting to give everybody enough
time you you 20 days
seems more reasonable if you're trying
to maneuver things around but now you're
just taking it from 20 to 70.
yeah and and seven is really the
consumer protection there that if you've
bought it you ought to have
possession of them and then be able to
uh make another trade or do what you
want with them
so that that's why barry glennon was
much more comfortable
um with with us and requested we moved
okay uh representative ben
houghton good morning thank you mr chair
and thank you senator for being here
i'm going to confess to complete
ignorance in this i did some research
uh checked it out a little bit more and
i have a couple of quick questions and i
hope that maybe someone will be
following you who will give us a primer
on this are you talking about physical
location location of the metals
and then a certificate to guarantee that
they are there
yes thanks for the question and i mean
that's the point
that you know you have to have in one
way or another
possession of the medals
and what we're saying is that the
possession here
can take place that they said there may
be could be sent to you personally
or you can designate a depository
in which they are held and i hope that
um
mr coda is on is available because he
trades in this and brought the issue to
my attention and i think he can
probably give you a pretty good sense of
just you know what the nuts and bolts
are of somebody
who participates in this these trades
okay he wasn't on my sheet but i'm
pulling them up
we do have we do have for further
questions yes representative van gaal
uh thank you and i thank you for that
explanation because that makes a lot of
sense to me
are there certain depositories that have
to be uh somehow certified somehow
safety certified because if i'm owning
diamonds which obviously i will be doing
shortly um
i want them safe how does that work
well um let's let's mr kota address that
but you'll see in the definitions part
there that it does say the depository
the warehouse receipts of which are
recognized for delivery purposes for any
commodity in a contract market
designated by the commodity futures
trading commission so
um and then uh storage facility licensed
or regulated by the united states for an
agency united states or a depository
designated by
et cetera so it's those sections of the
bill
that make sure that you're dealing with
a place that's recognized as licensed on
the up and up
thank you i just uh since i'm learning
about this uh piecemeal i'd like to be
sure that i'm guaranteeing safety of
investments for our constituents and
thanks very much
indeed thank you yeah representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question senator waters
um i'm totally ignorant
when it comes to bitcoin does this have
anything to do with bitcoin
uh no we um senator thanks for your
question senator sanborn introduced the
legislation a number of years ago
which authorized the people to use
bitcoin
if you're in new hampshire and that's a
different statute
okay thank you okay
uh any other questions representative
johnson has another question
thank you for taking my question again
what are the other 15 states that
are that you said that also have this
type of legislation
um you know i don't have the list in my
head but i'm pretty sure
that maine is one of them because i
looked at maine statute but
maybe uh miss dakota were there and and
again i'm
i'm you know i think barry glennon
thought he did his work
in the senate and getting the language
he wanted he signed off on it all so uh
i i don't i guess he's not here um today
for that part but this moment i have not
seen him yet but
yeah we'll see what happens but we do
have mr coda so he can help us yeah he
may be able to
okay help everybody ready thank you very
much senator
and we'll let you get back to busy work
taking care of house bills
okay i'll thank you and i'll see you
soon bye-bye
bye-bye so uh uh mr cutter
yes i'm here yeah great welcome
and uh and you know help us you've heard
a bunch of questions so i assume you've
got lots of
good material here for us yes uh well
i have uh i have bought and and sold
precious metals with a uh dealer and
they mail me uh the
the medals and when i want to sell them
uh i have to call them and
they send me a uh a box with a label
that i have to pack them and then send
them back and when they receive them
then i can sell them but i'm selling
them then at that price
at that time not at the price i would
want
to sell as if they were say stocks
uh and i also have to pay you know the
cost
of the shipping and the insurance which
is quite a bit
um and my uh
my broker at that at the company
told me that about this program where
they could store them in a depository
for me
and um i wouldn't have to pay for
shipping and i would get a lower
commission
and i'd be able to sell just by calling
and selling
and be able to sell immediately um and i
filled out the application
and then he told me oh uh there are five
states
uh in the united states where we are not
allowed
to use this option and new hampshire is
one of those
five states uh because it's against new
hampshire law
so um i could be across
the border in maine or massachusetts or
vermont or most of the country
and do this but i couldn't do it in new
hampshire because of the law
great you kind of moved over quickly so
what is the metal that you're doing and
and did you say dr like in dominican
republic or
like because i didn't follow you what
you were saying dominican republic no i
didn't no you said dr or something but
okay so where
what is the metal platinum platinum
they deal they deal in gold silver
platinum and palladium
and where is that entity where are you
getting this from california
california okay okay
uh let's see representative bartlett has
thanks very much um i'm sorry um i
mr coda i did not catch um your firm's
name
oh i don't have a firm i'm just as an
individual
so you're an individual who deals in
oh oh you mean the company that i buy
the um
[Music]
the medal from you're not representing
anybody is that correct
i'm not representing anybody no no okay
so you just purchase
these gems or precious metals from a
broker
is that correct yes okay thank you
okay uh
any other questions from the committee
members
uh seeing none we thank you for bringing
this bill
uh letting letting the senator know
about this and
because we don't like to be behind on
anything that comes to new hampshire but
oh we do have another question
representative mccleary uh thank you
uh mr coda are you dealing with
non-qualified
accounts or qualified accounts
uh i don't know what that means in other
words
i i have precious metals but it's it's
in a qualified account an ira account
and i never knew knew there was a
problem with that but you're talking
about
uh oh it's not an ira an ira
yeah not an ira okay that's all i wanted
to know thank you right
right you're you're just buying platinum
and
and then marking it up and selling it to
somebody else who might be making no no
no
i'm not marketing it to somebody else
the company that i deal with
maintains a two-way market and so i buy
from them and and if the price goes up
and i want to take a profit
i can sell it back to them ah
okay so you're basically they make a
profit on it
they make a margin but if the price goes
up by a significant amount i still make
money
so theoretically they're using your
money to go out and buy more metals and
you know you're basically somewhat of an
underwriter for them
they're well they're like a stock broker
except instead of
stocks they're selling actual physical
metal
amazing okay uh we do have more
questions
representative terry thank you mr
chairman
uh dare i ask senator waters or
mr cotta are you aware i think one of
you mentioned
these restrictions are in play do either
of you have any idea what the rationale
is or is this
is this just kind of legacy left over
from the way things were done in the
past and the other states have already
effectively reformed if i may answer
that um
and and i and i appreciate miss dakota's
correction too i think i had a typo
that i had 15 states instead of 45 so
i'm glad we got that straightened out um
but i
my sense is that we just haven't caught
up
uh here and um it's it's it's like a lot
of things i mean that 1985 is a long
time ago when it comes to markets
and a lot has a lot has changed so it uh
you know i mean it's similar to what
we've done in some other areas when
sometimes there's a constituent or a
business that comes forward and says
look we have to
we have to revise our bills i mean i
think back a few years ago we did that
massive
rewriting of the banking legislation
same thing it was an opportunity to
catch up on a lot of
a lot of things so i i think this is
just to catch up catching up with the
markets so that
individuals you know i mean again i i
strongly believe in free markets and an
individual
in new hampshire wants to participate in
the trading of investment metals and
investment gems that
they ought to be able to do it in in a
way that lets them
lets them operate so and i don't know
george if any other thoughts on that but
just it it's a great um would be a great
convenience to be able to have them
store it
and it would give me they would give me
a lower commission and i wouldn't have
to pay postage i would have to pay
uh a small monthly storage fee
but their storage fee is small compared
to the
uh other expenses and the values of the
metals
but you still have to take it back and
then ship it back to them and to put it
no i i would just i call them up i say i
want to buy
a certain amount of metal and i have
money in the account they use that money
in the account to buy it
and then they buy it and they put it in
storage
okay currently or with this legislation
with this legislation okay but currently
if you were to do that you would have to
have it shipped to new hampshire yes i'd
have it
yeah which has got to be shipping costs
insurance costs and
yeah loan vulnerability to handling
anything
so okay uh are you all set here for my
follow-up
for the for the question yes you may
inquire just to follow up i i
i never thought that um in moving from
rhode island to uh new hampshire that i
would be
moving behind the times but this is
one of those first in rare instances
where i was able to do something in
rhode island that apparently i would not
be able to do
yet in new hampshire and i hope we can
get this corrected thank you mr chairman
okay uh representative eminent has not
asked the question yet
thank you mr chair and this question is
for
mr coda as an individual
we talk about consumer protection is it
safer for you
to store the platinum in your house
or in a depository
i think it would be safer to store it in
a depository
and and because uh for the question
uh because you're at risk you're uh
providing your own security
to prevent theft and in a depository
they
i'm sure they have much better security
for you is that correct
okay representative van gaal you have a
new question
yes thank you and thank you for for
testifying to us today
um i have a very very basic question i
note that we're talking about investment
metal
is it always investment metal or at any
point does the metal become
jewelry for instance is it always
well it says investment gems too right
well
i don't know about the wording of this
of this bill but
um the only in metals the only things
that i
participate in with this uh broker are
if i may if i may um just mention
barry glennon said that he thought the
appropriate language was
investment medals and investment gems um
so that's why we have those terms in the
bill he thought he said in terms of
statute those are the words to use
so would we imagine that investment
means it might be a little more raw form
that it hasn't been turned into rings or
or the the diamond hasn't been uh
shaped yet i already call it when you
when you
chip away at a diamond and make it a
nice diamond
and i'm wondering too if it has to stay
in that form throughout
uh to qualify for this contract in other
words if i
if i sell my medals or my diamonds to a
jeweler do i now come out of this
contract with this business i i i i must
say that there's so much here that i
don't really understand and so my
questions are very basic and if you can
help me with it i'd appreciate that
it seems to me that again it's
investment so so
if you were a jeweler and you're going
to take that and start doing stuff with
it and then you're changing its form so
it's not
at that point it's not an investment per
se i would think
but i can we can certainly get barry get
him to respond to us for that question
are there any other questions for the
committee uh scene
we thank you very much and we'll close
the public hearing
uh we had five people in support um
looks like all senators and uh
and one i guess uh uh perkins
hug uh center oh it's a this is again
another senator okay so all senators
uh were in support five centers in
support no opposition and nobody neutral
now with that we'll close the public
hearing on
senate bill 138 and um
senator we don't exact bills on the same
day here in commerce
so uh stay tuned
we have a whole month exact thing so so
we're all set there
all right so the time being 10
27 so we have three minutes before we
and so i see yes okay you're also on
this one this one's under waters i see
okay
um so i'll ask the attendees if you
would like to speak on this bill just
raise your hand so i'll know
who's interested in speaking on this
bill
mr chairman yep uh since we have about a
minute and a half i just thought i would
take the opportunity to address the
question of um
representative van houghton with
particularly with respect to the
precious metals
that that we we're talking about um
uh gold silver platinum etc we're
talking about bullion
bars or we're talking about coins
or we're talking about slugs in other
words um
they look like coins but they're just
silver or gold or platinum but they're
they're there's no imprint upon them
some of the coins can be historic
coins and so it's it's it's a whole
range
of um product that's available um
for investment yeah but i see to me
um it's surprised that you say coins
because the coins are a finished
product so the value is not just in the
metal itself but it's in
all that you know the age and and the
stamp and whatever
like because it's a finished product
whereas when we talk about
when i think investment metals like you
say it's like it's like
gold bar you know that ingot and
so but like i said we learned something
new
every day in commerce and um and
just for the record i was elected in 86
it didn't
it was not around when this legislation
passed in 85.
i wasn't i was in new hampshire but i
was not an elected official at the time
okay it's 10 30. we'll open up the
public hearing
and the only center i got is you senator
waters
thank you mr chairman i just have part
three of this so i didn't know
how if you're going to proceed it's the
senator who was had
kavanaugh must be uh i know senate
commerce might be
busy so he is probably still over there
but
so um so you want to talk to section
three of the bill so that's fine
yeah thank you mr chairman i'd be happy
i'm senator david water district four
and let me just say that i am
introducing senate bill
um 1 24 and you'll see
uh it's and i'm almost sheepish to say
it's another one of the senate omnibus
bills why do they do
this mortgageborg or tasting menu i mean
at least this one is all about insurance
unlike some of which are
you know three or four different house
committees um
but you'll see the various underlying
parts to it and um
if if you if you would like mr chairman
uh since the others aren't here i can
speak
to um part three which is my partner
that's what i would like you to focus on
yeah
well thank you very much um so part
three uh is relative to self storage
insurance it's on page 13 of the of the
bill
is where it begins and um this may look
very familiar to you all
because uh you work did great work on it
last year and then it got all caught up
in covet so um
so here we are um and i will say it is
basically the same bill except for just
a couple little wiggles that the
insurance
commission um wanted so
um let me just go through it uh briefly
for you and we do have i believe some
representatives from the um
industry and uh let me also say that
this bill
um is actually the second second of
bills on
self storage we've dealt with over the
last several years
and here again really trying to to to
bring
our new hampshire statute up to date as
to how the industry
is functioning and i'm sure you all know
how important an industry
uh this is in in new hampshire
so what this bill does is it allows self
storage facilities to sell property
insurance
for its renters um
really the kind of key to it is uh on in
the definition
section um roman for uh
roman 8 you'll find on page 14 where it
defines self storage insurance
personal property insurance offered in
connection with an incidental to the
rental
of rented space at a self storage
facility
and provides coverage for loss or damage
of what's there or what's in
transportation
to and from it and this is important to
note this is a very limited
license for this it's just for this
product
it won't allow you to sell any other
kind of insurance it's just for
renters who want to take the convenience
here
and what's important to on page 15 uh
again trying to balance the um you know
commerce that
uh want people want to undertake and the
convenience that renters may want to
undertake
with appropriate consumer um protections
and so here
it says that very very clearly uh the
claims process
the costs of um the insurance
uh and the language there that must be
posted
um all be transparent and available
uh to the purchaser her purchaser here
um also important to note that this is a
policy that's limited to ten thousand
dollars and then again with the
with appropriate consumer protection
that the policies are regulated by
existing
insurance uh commission statutes rsa
for 12-5 two
um then the bill also goes into the
owner's responsibility
that the owners must provide the
appropriate training
they must have a plan for that training
that gets approved by the
commission they must establish an
appropriate and transparent
um billing uh procedure
and then there is language about license
application
and uh then also i think importantly too
just to notice the um effective date is
the first of january 22
so that it gives time for the insurance
commission and for
the industry to gear up get trained get
get their plans um
together get the appropriate materials
together decide whether they want to
offer this product
or or not uh so uh you know those of us
who've been around in new hampshire for
a while might remember that
the devastating fire at the storage
facility in portsmouth
um and it's just really important
that people have the opportunity to have
insurance if they
if they want to get it and this also
provides a
a very light touch of regulation that we
make sure that the product is being
presented and sold appropriately by
people who are trained to do it
but they are not full-time insurance
agents licensed to do
other things um and so this means that
it will be simple and impossible to
offer this product
uh for folks who are using rentage uh
and self storage facilities so mr
chairman um
there you have it okay and we do have
some questions
uh let's see who's first here uh so
first was representative burroughs uh
yes thank you for taking my question
um again this is new to me so um
it's more to understand why is
why does the the um the uh
property that that does the storage why
are they not
the ones who are carry the insurance
rather than the individual
owner people who rent out the storage
space
well thank you for your question i want
some industry folks here but
um you know i i always think i'm
responsible for my property
in a way you know if i'm in my house um
i i buy insurance uh for my for my
property um
i'm i'm sure that they have insurance on
their own building
but if it's my stuff or my car that's
being stored there
and i want to make sure that you know if
there's fire
or theft or whatever that i have
protection for my
for my property so that's that that's
the way i would
i would see it thank you okay
representative bartlett
um would you believe that you have to
have an insurable interest to be able to
purchase insurance so the self-storage
manager or owner doesn't have an
insurable interest in your
personal property so that's always a
basic um
i have to tell you that having an
insurance background this
at first blush makes it difficult for me
to
want to support this could you give me
um senator
waters could you give me a little um
background
about how this bill was presented and
whether the insurance department was
involved in
um i know you're talking about just part
three and whether the insurance
department was
um involved in in
presenting it well thank you for your
question um
uh representative bartlett and um as i
said this is the second year on this
and and your committee uh house commerce
worked on this
you know very effectively last last year
uh and then we you know covet disrupted
it
and all along there's been close work
with the
insurance department on language on
posting
some of the language here is what they
wanted the noticing they
asked for um considerable
changes both last year you know
particularly last year to get the
language where it ought to be and the
procedures where they
they ought to be on offering this
product um and i think that what's
significant here is that you know a lot
a lot of folks who get a storage unit
they're in between jobs they're
they're moving or they have one reason
they've got to have their
uh a storage facility and um it's and or
they got to get their a car stored
somewhere or a boat
and um you know it's a question of their
conv
convenience and also consumer choice um
you know that you'd have an opportunity
to at that at one
one place if you didn't already have um
homeowners or apartment insurance that
you get your
you could get your your possessions
insured for relatively low cost um
yes for the question being acquired
thank you um yes i'm aware that the
market
um to cover personal property in a
storage unit
is um is limited
and right if if you are between places
you aren't going to get an extension
past 30 days
during a moving process and of course
automobiles are not going to be covered
under your homeowners
you give this authority to a
self-storage
ownership or manager to sell insurance
um you
the the bill provides for training but
it talks about training but what is the
insurance department so
let me let me let me interject here
because i i believe i was a co-sponsor
of this bill
um so this is similar we've had several
one this is similar
is when you buy a cell phone
and you and they want to sell you an
extended warranty
for the cell phone and we had to do the
same thing with the legislation we had
to carve out that they weren't going to
be the same
deep structure that we require insurance
agents because this is just a service
being added on
by the uh storage facility so that
you get in the storage facility you've
just been notified that by the way
um you're obligated to ensure this
and and the person goes where where am i
going to find an agent where i
don't and they said well we actually
have that product here
and we can sell it for you if you would
like that
that's what this bill is i mean i i
understand ten thousand dollars is a
very small amount and
and by the time you're getting into
valuation of property that you're not
it's not in your possession um you know
that could be an issue but that's really
up to the insurance
adjuster to deal with um i i
i don't have a i don't have a big
problem with this but i sure would like
to get into the weeds a little bit
right right now we're just asking
questions yeah i understand thank you
okay all right uh next up is
yes thank you and thank you senator
waters uh for
for discussing this with us um i know we
worked on this uh this that house
commerce worked on this
um previously
i i'm unsure
however whether there well you mentioned
that the market
the the the current insurance market um
uh it's difficult to find an insurance
company that will cover this
uh in the in in our present statuses is
that correct or
did i misunderstand that thanks for your
question and i i didn't mean to imply
that i i
to me it's this question of convenience
and whether or not any coverage you have
would actually apply it might otherwise
have would actually apply
here and that's why we have the consumer
protection in the bill saying that that
uh the first the renter would be
informed
you may you may already have for
insurance on this uh
you know so it's like when you rent a
car you know you may already have
insurance
that covers this but you want to buy
ours um but as i said we do have i
believe we have
a representative from the national
industry and then uh representative from
new hampshire
uh facility who will be available to you
today
um and i think some they'll probably be
able to
give you some pretty good answers thank
you may i ask just a
quick follow-up okay so what you heard
there was that the senator was urging
you to maybe ask
mr all right i'll ask that later thank
you
so i guess the three people have your
hands up are you guys willing do you
have a question you think for the
senator or would you like to be able to
ask
well actually joe you probably know you
know
yeah you you actually have seen these
stories facilities so i can only imagine
your question's gonna be
but uh so bonnie are you okay with let's
uh call it
joe doherty to ask a question
[Music]
sure either way okay
because i'm just trying to figure out
chris you euchre i can mute you all
right
uh so um mr dougherty um yeah
you know please uh help us out here
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i'll just be brief in my
introduction of myself and then i'm
happy to answer any questions from the
committee so i i am the
uh in-house attorney for the national
self-storage association
we support this bill it's similar to
legislation that has been passed
in 40 states now including vermont
massachusetts and several other
nearby northeastern states
there are approximately 50
000 self-storage tenants in the state of
new hampshire
this provides them with a low-cost
option to get
insurance coverage this is something
that there
are you know there are markets for this
but it's difficult to get it through
and ensure an existing insurance agent
it's just you know the
the policies are very low dollar value
and there's not frankly a lot of
incentive for an insurance agent to sell
a standalone one of these policies
maybe it'll be a tag along to a
homeowners if you have one or something
like that but
as a standalone policy it's not
something we typically see
and with folks as senator waters
indicated with folks who are in
transition
if they don't have existing coverage
there is nothing to
tack on to it is however solely an
option
it's not something that can be forced
upon the tenant that is in the
disclosures that are provided to the
consumer so if you have
another form of coverage already great
that's fine and that you know that'll be
that'll be that and you'll be covered
through that finally i'll just point out
that these are
underwritten by known insurance
companies
maybe not household names per se but
names that are known within the industry
aig great american hanover and then the
the training that's provided and the
oversight that's provided for these
programs is provided by
licensed insurance agent so licensed
insurance agents
are involved in the process with that
training
with the oversight of the program but
they're not actually the person
standing behind the desk and for
efficiency's sake uh the
you know rather than licensing everybody
who might be standing behind a desk at a
self-storage facility
you have this process that's been
accepted in 40 other states now
where the employees of the facility work
under that license and again
are trained and overseen by uh by
licensed insurance agents again i'm also
happy to speak to the
uh you know speak to our discussions
with the insurance department but i
didn't want to
preempt any representative from the
insurance department who may be here
to to speak about that but i'm happy to
speak about that as well mr chairman
okay uh and you're willing to take
questions yes i am
all right so representative diploma
thank you uh for taking my question
um i was curious would this apply to
portable storage
companies that deliver self storage to a
customer's site
or would that only apply specifically at
a storage facility
representative de palma it would only
apply at us at a physical storage
facility would not apply to portable
storage units and have a follow-up mr
chairman for the question being acquired
if that storage company did have a self
storage facility on site and also did
portable storage
could they still offer the insurance or
would that be
that wouldn't be allowed they could
offer the insurance
to you for folks who had a unit at the
site
but if you know if something you know my
neighbors here
in my community that you know they'll
have a portable storage unit sitting in
their driveway
you couldn't use it to ensure that you'd
have to
you but you could probably get that on
your homeowners as well but if the
if if the property were stored at the
site of the storage facility it could be
insured under this
type of policy if you get a my box
and have it deliver your home you got to
get your homeowners to cover it
but if you get the my box right there at
the site of the of
their rental business then it would be
okay
good question all right and now
representative ham
yes thank you very much for taking my
question i think my question was
kind of answered i was concerned these
uh these contracts these insurance
policies are sold through
an insurance company a licensed
insurance company
underwritten by that company so you have
a
an independent um agent there in between
the
um storage unit uh owner
and the tenant so that kind of um
clarified my concern thank you
[Music]
and representative johnson thank you for
taking my question
um actually i've got two the first one
um
is there a um
and i could be reading it wrong does the
storage facility
that is offering this insurance are they
going to be making
a commission or a profit on selling this
insurance
mr chairman representative johnson yes
there is
a potential for compensation to the
storage facility
and and that is yeah that's something
that's part of the
the existing fee structure that's
disclosed to the insurance department on
on the filings with the department
follow-up question for the question we
inquire
um well
so the story would the storage facility
have to could they
mandate that people who rent from them
now have to buy this insurance in order
to rent from them
is this going to something that can come
down the line where they can try to
mandate this if you want to use a
specific facility
mr chairman representative johnson no
they cannot that that is specifically
addressed in
in the law and it's a specific
disclosure given to the consumer that
this cannot be mandated
thank you you're welcome great
all right any other questions for
attorney gaurdi
seeing none we thank you very much for
your testimony thank you mr chairman
uh so i do see
um actually oh senator kavanagh
i'm gonna i'm gonna actually i'm gonna
um i'm gonna promote
um attorney fox and i'm going to promote
senator kavanagh um
and i guess briefly uh jim are you are
are you going to talk are you i assume
the couple of things on this on the on
these bills or
you're going to talk to or any is this
one one of them that you were going to
talk
about yeah i'm sorry
my computer went uh went out for a
second uh yeah that happens when i
switch you over
i'm gonna i'm gonna talk to uh the self
storage um
one the travel insurance one in the
domestic insurance investment
one and i think tyler brandon is gonna
handle the medicare one
perfect okay all right so uh i'm going
to hold you for a moment you guys
because
we always like to uh help senators out
first
so uh senator cavanaugh hints you are
the prime sponsor of this bill
and um welcome to the house commerce
committee
thank you very much i apologize to the
committee for being late i had a
commerce meeting and then i had the
wrong zoom address i was trying to get
on but i kept on going to uh judiciary
and i had to get this link so i
apologize
so i'm not sure where you are but i can
just present what i have
yeah and then if that's her right yes
that'd be great
um my name is kevin cavanaugh senator
from district 16
representing the towns of beau candia
dunbarton hooksett the manchester awards
uh one two and 12. and i'm here to speak
to section one of uh senate bill 124
i was approached by the industry to
sponsor senate bill 415
last year which passed i'm sorry about
that senate commerce
5-0 with an amendment agreed to by the
industry and the insurance department
it is based on the national association
of insurance commissioners model
legislation
built on the need for states to have a
clear regulatory framework for insurance
travel insurance
it has passed in 11 states and being
considered in many other states this
year
this section of the bill will benefit
consumers by requiring
explicit consumer disclosures prohibit
opt-out sales
applicability of the state's unfair
trade practices act
additionally it will empower power the
department of insurance
currently regulations for travel
insurance are based mostly on health
insurance law
and limited to distinguishing aspects of
travel insurance
from major medical and or other
categories of health insurance
the rules were a creative approach to
providing guidance and this bill
attempts to build off that work
and allow the department to create rules
and procedures beyond the current
limited scope
finally the bill will ensure a fair
marketplace
by addressing travel insurance elements
not in current regulations
specifically the bill defines travel
retailers
travel administrators travel protection
plans and sales practices
you will hear additional testimony from
the industry on the importance of these
provisions
in conclusion i ask you to support
section 1 of senate bill 124 fn
which would create an efficient
effective regulatory framework for
travel insurance
by adding clarity to existing laws and
regulations for the travel insurance
industry
in a way that benefits consumers
empowers regulators and ensures
a fair marketplace so thank you
committee members and again i apologize
mr chairman for being late thank you
right i
see um representative has his hand up so
i hope you can
make sure you that testimony you just
gave you can have it submitted to the
committee
sure i'll get it right i'll get it over
to you okay
great uh so is there any other uh
questions for the senator
okay well thank you very much uh thank
you very much i'm gonna jump back to
commerce then
i uh take good care
thank you representative bye everyone
yeah okay
uh senator d'alessandro
i assume care about this bill yep thank
you very much
mr chairman and uh
chairman hunt and distinguished members
of the committee for the record i'm
senator lou d'alessandro i represent
district 20.
that's manchester awards 3 4 10 11 of
the town of goffstown
and i come before you as the sponsor of
a proportion of this omnibus bill last
session
the senate passed senate bill 416
however like other parts of of this bill
it died on the table
part two was refiled at the request of
the liberty mutual group
which owns 18 new hampshire-based
insurance companies
in total they employ over 3 500 people
throughout the state
and additionally the investments held by
those
subsidiaries are worth over 25 billion
dollars
rsa 402 colon 28 governs the types of
investments
that domestic insurance companies can
make in new hampshire
part two of this bill would add
replications to the list of permissible
investment transactions
they can make replications are a
combination of a bond and a derivative
that are intended to replicate the
performance of an asset
that an insurer is permitted to make
under existing law
currently 30 states allow domestic
insurers to invest in replications
essentially part 2 would allow liberty
mutual and other domestic insurers
to use replication transactions along
with other derivative transactions
to better access financial markets now
it's it's a shame but uh
attorney russo who who usually testifies
on
on this bill is in the hospital and
underwent emergency surgery but i'm sure
that people from liberty mutual are here
and others who can give you a a very
very complete answer to questions that
that you may come up with i i thank you
for the opportunity to uh appear before
you representative
thank you so much and uh nice to see all
of you you know it's
these in these terrible times that we
don't see anybody
and uh it's a pleasure to see all of you
and and to appreciate your service
uh during this period of time it's not
easy but
nothing nothing is easy in this life
thank you so much for doing what you do
with that representative hunt i
appreciate the opportunity to come
before you and
uh any questions i i could answer i'd be
happy to do that but i'm sure there are
others here who can give you
a much better by the way the insurance
companies support the insurance
department supports this
uh we've gone by uh run it by the
commissioner and uh
you may not he or someone else may be
here uh to testify but
but again thank you representative
always a pleasure to see the
so uh thank you senator uh just make
sure that that wonderful testimony you
just gave that you uh
upload that uh so that uh it'll be in
as we speak thank you so much all right
excellent
um so uh
representative excuse me senator sherman
i assume you're here for 125
uh yeah for the next bill
no i'm here for 120 for the last section
oh perfect great all right well then
you're on
all right thank you uh mr chair and
this is uh probably i think the briefest
bill i've ever submitted but
this is uh essentially a bill that i
worked with
tyler brandon on recognizing that
when you have a medicare supplemental
insurance and you are
disabled and under 65 you then
when you turn 65 you continue medicare
supplemental insurance
but there was a practice that was not
ubiquitous
but it was clearly occurring where the
insurance companies
would not tell you that you actually are
eligible for a
much less expensive supplemental
insurance policy when you turn 65.
so the original bill which was filed
last year and
died a coveted death uh is back
it's better than ever it's shorter and
uh senator daniels who as you know works
in this
uh arena um actually
fixed a a section of it that would have
had unintended consequences so
this is incredibly simple it just says
that when
you turn 65 and you're disabled
you um uh no issuer
shall continue to charge that member the
under 65 premium which
is uh universally higher than the
over 65 premium so it it gives you that
automatic
shift to the new premium when you turn
and stops the practice of
continuing a higher charge for those who
were not aware that they are
continuing to be charged at the under 65
rate
perfect any questions for senator
sherman we do have representative
see if i can get this working can you
hear me yes we can
all right uh thank you for taking my
question um so this is on part four of
the bill
uh i'm reading uh page 17 lines 23 and
24.
it says upon a medicare eligible
disabled
member obtaining the age of 65 no issuer
shall continue to charge that member of
the under age 65 premium
um but it doesn't say
more or less would they be allowed to
charge a war
under this bill
uh technically
uh yes you know it's not telling
insurance companies
what that charge over 65 would be but
the problem is that in
across all carriers and and i think
tyler can answer this
even better than i can because he's the
one who monitors this
the medsup is less expensive when you
turn 65
than when you are under 65
and disabled so the the
process was that they would continue to
charge
the under 65 rate which was higher
even though the person was eligible for
a lower rate but it
uh did not but they were not required to
to notify or to change to the lower rate
yeah that makes sense because you're
under 65 you're many technically you're
medically underwrited
whereas over 65 it's mandated that
there's no
under no underwriting occurring correct
so
that makes sense but that's a good
question
uh i didn't understand oh my god my
sorry about that um let's see
uh i guess what i'll do um
tyler let me you might as well have
tyler come up and
are you are you there tyler or did i
yeah i hope
you guys can't yeah yep great wouldn't
you go ahead and talk about
uh this one while we're doing medicare
at this moment
so tyler brandon life and health
director with insurance department
um we don't actually have a position on
the bill
but most of what i would say is
favorable and it wasn't a department
request
this is a little bit of a funny
situation
we have received complaints from
consumers who have been continued
with that disabled premium which i think
was explained before
is higher so we don't regulate medicare
advantage or medicare but we do have a
limited role with medicare
supplemental and there are essentially
two open enrollment periods possible if
you're disabled
so you can qualify for medicare under 65
when you're disabled
and then of course you qualify for
medicare when you turn 65.
there are rating rules that we approve
that the premiums
and new hampshire has what's referred to
as an issue age so
the problem seems to be that some people
who
qualified being disabled weren't
notified that they had another open
enrollment period when they turned 65
continued to be charged the higher
disabled premium
and then complained to the department
when they found out they should have had
the opportunity to get a lower premium
so this very simple bill just addresses
those people when they turn 65
provides that regulatory clarity we
actually
uh surveyed the carriers to find out
what they were doing
and one of the carriers a major player
in the market said
we would never continue to charge that
disabled rate when somebody turned 65
that's illegal so clearly um one way or
another the regulatory clarity would be
helpful
that being said there does seem to be a
lot of support for acknowledging the
fact that when somebody who's disabled
turns 65
they qualify for that that regular 65
premium that would be in place um so i'm
happy to take any questions
and uh thank you seems pretty
straightforward to me
okay uh thank you very much okay so
attorney
fox you're going to wrap up the other
three
three yeah okay my name is james fox i'm
the pnc director at the new hampshire
insurance department
um thank you for having me i think uh
since we have all three maybe i'll go in
reverse order so
this so i'll go back to self storage um
the self storage bill we were i would
say
in my opinion very heavily involved in
the drafting of that
um and for those of you know the
the biggest license you can have in
state of hampshire produces is is the
402j that's our full license uh you can
sell homeowners insurance
any type of insurance if you have that
line so that that's our our big
um producer license and under that we
have these limited licenses for what
i think really lesser products and this
is self storage and then it allows
self storage facilities to in essence be
able to sell the product with an insurer
sitting above them
um now in this one we were uh a little
more concerned because it is personal
property you can have quite a bit of
personal property in your storage
facility
so we may we put some things in place
that aren't really in the
other limited lines like there it has to
be training um and we have
to approve the training we limited it to
the ten thousand dollars so we didn't
want to have large
value policies that you weren't going to
a 402 j producer
um and we did look at it was mentioned
all 40 states we looked at all
pretty much all 40 states to try to pick
out the best
pieces of each state um for consumer
protection so all we're going to look at
all the forms
it's going to be form approval as a
training approval
and i would say uh of the lines this is
probably
um the most regulated of the limited
lines
so that the the commissioner also
personally reviewed this one and he's
very comfortable
um that it is sufficiently consumed
protective
um that we can let it go forward so i'm
happy to take any questions about it
okay okay
and then maybe then i'll move up to
travel since it's related
now travel insurance again is a limited
line the travel insurance law
402 l is already in place
and it's a much abbreviated version
now in new hampshire it's a little
unusual because we have a abbreviated
limited alliance license for travel
insurance and then
under that we have a very extensive rule
so when we were brought the neic model
what several of our attorneys uh did was
they basically made sure because we
think our rule is working well
that the neic model we put in place was
consistent with the rule
so in essence you have the expanded
protections
as to defining the exact rules all the
parties involved the travel agency
the education that's required what's
allowed to allow to be done what's not
allowed to be done
what disclosures need to be put in place
so a lot of that's new and it's
it's more let's call it consumer
friendly and then also underneath that
we have our very extensive rule on how
the insurance is supposed to work
so again based upon our input um we're
very comfortable that this
is at the right level of consumer
protection for this name peril
type of policy and as always uh if
you know we get some complaints and
something's not working out correctly
then we'll come back and tweak it but
right now
a lot of work was put into making sure
the rule
and versus uh and the statute will work
well together and
uh i would say it's uh much more
protective for consumers than the old
much more revealed any questions
okay okay and the last one um
is again an naic model it's the domestic
insurance company
uh investment uh law this is again so
that this is what applies to our
domestic
the new hampshire based insurance
companies
and it allows them as was mentioned what
we did basically is take the old law
which is very abbreviated as derivative
transactions
and remove that and our director of
financial regulation
doug bartlett worked very extensively on
putting
taking the neic model and putting that
in place which is a much more detailed
model and what you're allowed and not
allowed to do as to investments
and one of the big things it does again
is to allow replication transactions
which
you know for us more lay people that
just allows the insurance company to
replicate something
um in a synthetic way that they're
already allowed to do so it's not
something that they weren't allowed to
do it's something that basically they've
always done and they're just replicating
it
uh and again our from our position is
you know the naic model so that's the
national association insurance
commissioners
um and that's in all 50 states
and this makes it 11 level playing field
so liberty mutual asks for this so we'd
want to make sure
that in new hampshire uh liberty mutual
with our oversight regulation to make
sure for solvency is able to do
and be competitive with insurance
companies in other states so
that's all that the goal of that
particular section
was to accomplish
uh doug bartlett you know senator
bartlett is also here if they say you
really
just like to know about replication
transactions because right
first okay um
i don't anyway it's okay i'll
i can't talk i don't know where the echo
is coming from
okay i i think the echo was me i just
okay
it's okay now so you're on would you
believe i'm i'm
much more comfortable after hearing from
you mr fox we should have put you on
first
okay uh all right so
uh only other person i have signed up
for to speak
is michael byrne and
good morning mr burns good morning um
thank you everybody for your time mr
chairman and members of the committee
my name is michael byrne i represent the
united states
travel insurance association otherwise
known as
ustia ustia's members include
insurance carriers third party
administrators insurance agencies
and related businesses involved in the
development administration and marketing
of travel insurance and travel
assistance products
we very much appreciate the opportunity
to talk with you today
ustia is very supportive of
senate bill 124 particularly section one
of the bill
which is important as mentioned by
senator cavanaugh
and uh mr fox uh important for travel
consumers
regulators and the industry um and we
thank you mr chairman
uh and members of the committee for
taking up the legislation today
um and obviously thank senator kavanagh
for for his support
um and and mr fox for his work and the
department's
um efforts to incorporate um the nasc
and encoil model um into new hampshire
law
we don't need to restate what what the
senator mr fox presented which we
we very much echo and support and just
want to say that
we urge the committee to pass the bill
and thank you again for your time and
happy to answer any questions about
about the legislation uh representative
bartlett did you have a question or is
your hand i do
okay i do um thank you very much i'm not
trying to be facetious with this
question but i'm wondering if you have
had any
travel insurance companies go out of
business in the past year
uh not that i'm aware of uh certainly
not insurance companies that i'm aware
of
thanks very much i'm sure there's plenty
of claims
well all i can say is uh to for me to
get into the
british virgin islands i had to buy
travel insurance which i've never bought
before
and they did give a list of companies
that are are available and there were
six different companies and i think i
went with the shurian
because i knew the name but uh but so
it's obviously a very lively
market in that business so all right uh
having
no more questions and no more hints i
think we're all set we can close the
public hearing
on senate bill 124 we had 16 in support
no opposition and two neutral which i
believe are insurance department people
and with that we'll end that public
hearing and now
we'll go to the last but not least
our favorite subject beer
and we'll have
so the prime sponsor is uh senator
gannon i know he was here
here we go so i'm gonna promote him up
here
and good morning senator gannon and i'm
sorry about the
probably he was in paper lane and didn't
hear me
dude there we go can you hear me all
right perfect
great i'm sorry i'm in the middle of
commerce too and so i've been
listening in and out and it's hard to
follow my favorite senator lou de
salasandro
he is the chairman um but anyways
so i talked with your chairman yesterday
and
um i felt much like my kids when they
come home from junior higher high school
with their paper and that's me and they
thought they knew everything on a
subject
and i learned humbly that um it's
some things aren't your wheelhouse and
what seems very easy
isn't always as easy as it seems so i
appreciate senator hunt's
patience with me don't don't don't know
me representative hunt
i'm sorry representative um so anyways
i'll tell you why i started the bill
where we're out with it so
um and i had no real knowledge outside
of drinking and enjoying beer
till december of this uh last year so
the no microbrewers everyone came to me
and they said
uh here's an industry that generates 506
million dollars
helps our tourist industry i'm watching
people go from vineyard to vineyard
throughout the state
and i'm like wow this is great we can
have the same thing going you know
tourists coming up i have one a mile
from me uh
it's called what is it called zurbino
vineyards and they are packed
seven days a week in the summer and i'm
like wouldn't this be a good thing for
every town that has a small nano brewery
a micro brewery
and again providing 4 700 jobs
the average pay is 42 000 we're all
about the new hampshire advantage
seemed like a total no-brainer to me but
then you get into the weeds
as senator hunt knows and there's a long
history with the bill
uh not just that the whole industry has
much much more detail than i know
but i'll give you my summary of it and
we'll go from there um
so i introduced the bill after i said
geez let's spread more jobs in new
hampshire sounds like a great idea
um so the bill is intended sought to
simplify the statutes governing the
craft beer industry
to enable more competitive with the
surrounding states bring more businesses
in and help our local breweries
the senate committee we testified in our
committee first
and the original bill would have had an
indeterminate effect on the liquor
commission's three-tier system which
consists of manufacturers wholesalers
and resellers so we amended the bill
i think i talked to probably all 92
micro brewers nano brewers
and so we amended it we talked to the
liquor commission the wholesalers the
craft
brewers and then it came what we came
out with then was
um we tried not to fundamentally alter
the three-tier system
instead we just tried to increase the
amount of beverages allowed to be sold
at a manufacturer's facility permit the
nano brewers and the brew pubs to
contract brew
and allow for interstate shipment of
specialty beers
and permit beverage manufacturers and
licensees to have a retail outlet
just one besides where they make their
main manufacturing
and to sample produce much like lebel
brewer is doing
near by me in hampstead they're having a
satellite uh winery and
they don't have to make the product
there uh they can just
um have like a sampling room to spread
their product so
the idea was you if you were brewing up
in uh
uh somewhere far up town i don't want to
insult anyone say the town's far and
we'll just say like in berlin or
somewhere and you could have a satellite
location
in portsmouth um you could spread your
your label you get people to come try a
little bit of your beer
and hopefully generate a buzz and get
your products sold
and again help helping new hampshire
businesses what we're all about
um i have since talked to uh
chairman hunt and found out there's a
lot more to it than i probably
know and or will ever understand so i'm
going to defer to him in the committee
to explain where i may be off and i
think there are going to be people
testifying now after
me on both sides from manufacturers
distributors and they understand that
there's a 20-year history on this going
back and forth
and so i would ask that you ask them the
questions i would
listen intently and try to bring myself
up from
a basic understanding to a higher
understanding listening to everyone's
testimony
and i believe chairman hunt um may later
have an amendment which he thinks covers
a lot of these issues and um i would ask
that you
i can't try to answer questions but i
think um you'd be my your time would be
better spent
dealing with the people who really
understand the the ins and outs and the
weeds
and that's it chairman thank you did the
room empty
no yeah oh no they just showed an empty
room and
that's usually when i tried to tell a
joke there's no one left at the end
you're right you're on the committee
room yeah no i my space bar didn't work
that time to uh okay um okay so uh thank
you very much senator okay
thank you very much you have a great day
thank you chairman and uh
do good work over there in commerce i'm
gonna head back over there now thank you
great thank you um all right so i will
next
call up is uh aiden moore
uh yeah i've pulled you up already aiden
i know you you have an appointment that
you have to attend to so
i thought we would get you to tell us
what you think of this
legislation uh good morning chairman
hunt and committee members
can you hear me all right yes we can
thank you
my name is aiden moore i am the legal
coordinator for the state liquor
commission
and i just thought we would like to at
least offer you some
thoughts on uh senate bill 125
working off amendment 0745
s can can i confirm that
with you chairman uh sure why not i
uh do i have that i have uh
o745s yes that's what it says on the top
yes
as amended by the senate yes thank you
sir
uh just to cover some of the things that
are in this and
um the commission has been working with
some members of the industry to help
fashion some of these changes
as was mentioned by senator gannon
and for those who would like to follow
along i can try to briefly address
the seven parts of this bill
section one uh removes some of the
limitations that has been put in place
for the purposes of uh limiting the
quantities that
a consumer can buy at a beverage
manufacturer's facility
we thought that was a an easy change
that
would bring about some opportunities for
consumers
sections two three
and four are
parts of this bill which essentially are
dealing with
contract brewing that
will allow nanobrewers and brewpubs to
engage in contract brewing now
uh senator excuse me sections two three
and four
have already been amended and this the
language that you see in this bill is
the exact language
that appears in the amendment to senate
bill 17
brought by senator sherman so it appears
in two places you see
you'll see it here in this bill and it
also appears
as an amendment in senate bill 17 which
i believe
the committee has already taken up your
committee has already taken up
representative fund
for its first introduction so you may be
seeing that again
section five is a section that deals
with the
intra-state shipment of alcohol
as you know senate bill excuse me rsa
27 is a bill that was
passed long ago to allow for businesses
who were licensed out of the state of
new hampshire
to obtain permits to ship products into
the state of new hampshire
and section 5
would allow and create the language as
well as the
labeling and reporting requirements
for businesses who are licensed within
the state to ship to consumers
located within new hampshire and
uh so there that process and again it's
uh what is important i think for the
committee to know
is that the permits that would be part
of this
are not subject to fees we're not going
to
ask the legislature to impose any
additional fees to
obtain the right to ship within the
state of new hampshire
section 6 deals with
what i guess is commonly been referred
to as satellite locations
um i think it is important to note that
on line 18 on page four
of the bill you'll see the word uh
at the end of the sentence retail
outlets
uh this certainly would appear to
be authorizing um if this were to become
law
a beverage manufacturer to obtain
more than one retail outlet
and we felt that that certainly
and section 7 creates a new definition
of
a beverage manufacturer retail outlet
and again we've kind of framed this in
the
in the in the phrase of a satellite
location
which would allow a beverage
manufacturer
and then the terms that are contained
within
this definition are conditions precedent
to getting the satellite location
and it should be brought to your
attention that
the way this statute is constructed that
a beverage
manufacturer who would be seeking a
satellite location
would need to manufacture product
at the site of that retail location in
order to be eligible
so uh mr chairman that's our assessment
of uh senate bill 125 as amended in the
senate
and i'd be happy to take any questions
from committee members
representative weston you have a
question nope
and thank you mr moore for taking my
question as you mentioned we are
pretty familiar with the main part of
this because of
sb17 and there's uh there are a couple
figures in there that have confused me
all along um which refer
to the the maximum amount that can be
produced by a nano brewer and a brew pub
and i'm wondering why those two amounts
are not the same
a nano brewer is limited to um
yeah 2500 and why are they different uh
thank you for your question
representative um i can tell you the
the brewpub uh preceded the uh
nanobrewers as far as its capacity it
was rather a new creation that kind of
came a number of years ago um with the
idea that
a restaurant that is interested in
brewing its own beer for its customers
would have the ability to do so
so uh i'm going to guess well in excess
of probably 20 25 years ago
the capacity of 2500 was placed in that
statute
i think for uh the nanos i was i was not
present for working with the commission
at that time
but i think the idea is that the 2000 is
a
reasonable level for what would probably
be referred to as an incubator business
a business that's looking to start up
and that if they were to exceed that
they would then move on to the next
classification of
license which would be a beverage
manufacturer's license
so um i can't speak to the historical
reason why those numbers are there but
that would i believe appear to me to be
why they
exist the way they do representative
thank you very much
there is an order here okay
representative bartlett is next
thank you very much um mr moore could
you know that we're dealing with these
omnibus bills and
um senate bill 17 has two parts of it
and
would you be able to clarify for us that
senate bill
125 includes everything that's
in 17 on the second part
uh yes that that was uh
i believe the intent when this came
across
um is that when senate bill 17 was
amended by senator sherman
to add this language dealing with
senator birdsell to amend the bill
which he consented to and it was amended
we worked with the
senator and the industry to make sure
that that language was
tight and it was reintroduced
into senate bill excuse me senate bill
as the industry sought to again have
that type of
privilege included in in its in this
legislation so we've we've duplicated it
but i can confirm that to you
thank you very much thank you
representative
thank you and thank you mr moore i'm
going to ask the question that i've
asked a couple of times as we've heard
um
liquor bills uh the three-tier system
in my opinion seems to be perhaps the
word is too strong but unraveling in
some ways
um are we better to better off to just
maybe
establish a commission or something of
that sort to look at the skeleton
of the three-tier system to be sure that
we are not destroying it by bits and
pieces and i do respect your
your you need to not be uh partisan here
uh to to have some neutrality but are we
in general eroding the system
in some ways thank you for your
questions uh
um i i think that
each year and for those of you who have
been members of the general court for a
number of years you've seen bills come
each year and
it oftentimes is not clear what the
impact of that legislation will be
immediately
one might think it's clear but it does
change the dynamic and i think the
not that every system needs to be static
and never change
and certainly over the course of my time
working for the state of new hampshire
i've seen
a dramatic change in this area but i
also think
and i think probably most everyone who
has an interest in this area would agree
that
there needs to be balance and that the
process
needs to be complex and
there are a lot of interlocking pieces
and when
you are at the cusp of potentially
making some significant change it
is i believe critical to um
look at the long-term effects and ask
how is this change going to affect other
parts of the system so to the extent
that you've described representative
the need to kind of examine things in a
very global sense
i think that would uh that makes a great
sense
okay all set uh representative
mclaren uh thank you mr chairman mr
moore i
i thought i heard something that was a
little bit uh
contradictory um first off i think
i heard that we could have a brewery
could have one satellite
you said something about more than one
well i'm thank you for your question
representative um
i i believe and again this may be a
scribner's error
but the way uh the
language is written on page four line
eighteen
it could be interpreted that uh the word
outlets is plural
and that the and that the intent made to
have
baby to have one satellite location but
the way the law is written it could be
very reasonably interpreted to be more
i think he's pointing out that it needs
to be amended to have that fixed
okay and a follow-up um i
thought you also said that the satellite
uh
facility would have to brew as well and
i originally heard that
the satellite facility would not have to
have a brewing
situation can you clarify that well
thank you for your
follow-up question representative um i'm
i'm just looking at the
language that is in the amendment
745 i don't know what future amendments
if any might bring
um in the way of changing that but the
way the
bill that is before your committee now
reads
um it does require a satellite location
or a
beverage manufacturer retail outlet to
produce
product on-site to be eligible to hold
so again this is another item that needs
to be amended and fixed
to clarify this all right representative
abel
thank you all right thank you um thank
you mr moore
um uh my question
uh involves the ability
of the liquor commission to
uh keep track of what's brewed
and what uh what's what's sold
um so that um
revenue that that's due to the due to
the state
is is um is adequately uh accounted for
and collected
is there any any problem with that at
all in this
uh thank you for your question
representative uh certainly the the
commission takes its
uh responsibilities to audit and
maintain
uh proper reporting as part of its
duties to ensure uh the revenue owed the
state is collected
it is a i will say a challenge we try to
make sure that we're
keeping up with that as the laws change
and the reporting of the licensees who
are required to file taxes
um is maintained and current
so when when we see some of these
uh changes you know we always try to
look at that and that's always part of
our fiscal worksheets that we provide if
we see anything that
we feel is going to have a fiscal impact
on this
but i don't see any anything in this
representative that
i would say would necessitate or cause
us to
have any significant budgetary
challenges um
and and again that may change if if the
bill is amended further
um but at this point in time i think i
think we seem to be prepared to handle
great uh representative emin has a
question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh is it true that
the satellite facilities would have to
be for a
single brewer or
or vineyard that they cannot combine
resources and create
a satellite retail space that
sold multiple producers
products is that correct uh thank you
for your question representative and i
would say your
your answer your your question is
correct that the way the bill is drafted
a beverage manufacturer would
be able to have a satellite location and
only sell their products they could not
sell anybody else's products
thank you okay
see no more questions then i guess
we'll move on so i'll call up kirsten
neves
and who is in support of the bill
and she's from tuckerman brewing
hi committee members uh thank you for
taking the time to hear me
um i'm kirsten nebs i'm co-founder of
tuckerman brewing company and i'm also
vice president of the new hampshire
brewers association
and i support sb 125 we opened tuckerman
brewing company in 1998 and in 23 years
we've seen
significant change in the craft brewing
industry in new hampshire when we opened
people would mainly come to the brewery
to take tours and maybe have a quick
sample
and if we were lucky we would we could
convince them to buy a six-pack on their
way out
but hardly anybody took us up on it um
and over the last two decades we've
watched as brewery tasting rooms have
become increasingly popular with locals
and tourists
and tasting rooms have become an
integral part of the communities that
they're located in
our customers are from all walks of life
locations and age groups and our tasting
room serves as a community meeting place
for everyone
unfortunately over the years the
licensing and regulations pertaining to
new hampshire breweries has not kept
pace with the brewing industry
other states around us have had far
fewer restrictions and regulations on
breweries
and they're able to offer their
customers a more fluid and comfortable
tasting room experience
if new hampshire breweries want to keep
up the pace of the ever-evolving growing
industry we need to be able to work
without the burdens of over-regulation
sb-125 takes steps towards allowing new
hampshire breweries to compete with
breweries and
neighboring new england states sba 125
would help our particular business by
eliminating the one case per person per
day limit on what we can sell
to customers for offsite uh consumption
that's extremely
confusing to try to explain to customers
especially from tourists from out of
state
it would also allow us to have a
satellite location in a more heavily
trafficked area of our town
our brewery is located in industrial
park and our customers have to really
seek us out to find us
also if we could open a satellite
location we could open in a
in a different part of the state that
doesn't have the seasonal fluctuation
fluctuations that we do in the north
country um
also important of a satellite location
that would allow us to introduce
varieties of
our products that can't be sold in
stores there's tremendous competition
for shelf space
in retail and chain stores and also a
lot of the beers that we brew
have special instructions for
refrigeration and handling
that only a brewer could explain to a
customer or would possibly want to
explain to a customer
we have 13 beers on draft right now in
our tasting room and only six of those
are distributed through our distributors
throughout the state
and that's because of those reasons and
also on behalf of my role as the vice
president of the nhva
sva sp 125 would help our members in a
number of ways
it would allow contract brewing to be
performed by a beverage manufacturer for
any brewery license type
currently a beverage manufacturer can
only contract room for another beverage
manufacturer
uh sb 125 would also allow new hampshire
breweries
direct shipped to customers in new
hampshire currently only out of state
breweries are allowed to direct ship to
new hampshire which is a great
disadvantage to our breweries uh svi
sp 125 would allow craft breweries of
any size to have satellites so
satellite locations which would bring
parity with new hampshire wineries who
are allowed to have
satellite locations regardless of their
size
also i would like to read a statement
from ariel moe who is co-founder of
stone face brewing and treasurer of the
new hampshire brewers association and
errol says that he has surmised that the
state will
realize incremental tax revenue of one
hundred to one hundred fifty thousand
dollars if just
five to ten percent of beverage
manufacturers chose chose to open a
satellite location
uh that option creates growth
opportunities for our small businesses
and translates into new jobs across
geographic regions
but thank you very much for hearing me
out and please let me know if you have
we do have a question representative
burrows
yes kirsten thanks for taking my
question
um i'm i'm just confused because i'm i'm
reading
um some of the verbiage on page four of
the bill
and i've been to tuckerman's in conway
um you do a lot of great things for
her charities etc do you have a limit on
the amount of um
amount of servings you can have in that
i'm sorry uh the sb 125 doesn't really
pertain to the pint limits it pertains
to
off-premise cons off-premise sales
so what sp sp 125 tries to fix is uh
that we're
if somebody comes to the brewery and
wants to buy some beer to go
they can only buy one case or one keg
per person per day
okay so this wouldn't limit how much you
serve in the conway facility
no it wouldn't address the plant limits
at all
there's a separate statute that relates
to that that's all right because i see
people sitting there a long time that
would have surprised me thank you
thank you okay any other questions from
the committee uh thank you very much all
right
now for the other side of mike summers
from uh
restaurant and hospitality uh good
morning mr chairman uh thank you for
tuning in to speak to you for the record
my name is mike summers i'm the
president ceo of the new hampshire
lodging and restaurant association
and for the most part this bill we don't
really have a concern with i think the
one thing that has
been touched on a couple of times in
testimony are the satellite locations
and
as i understood in the initial days of
this bill the intent was to have one
satellite location
per brewery which you know we could
probably live with that
but again uh through the um amendment
process we ended up with this version
which um
i think i'm in agreement with uh former
chief moore
that the way it's written right now
ultimately a brewery could have you know
10 15 or more locations
uh which would create a concern for the
industry for us for the restaurant
industry because now we're essentially
going to have
you know beer bars with no food
requirements competing potentially next
door to our restaurants that have all
the food requirements and all the other
overhead that
is required to be carried based on our
licensing structure so
that really is our concern and again it
sounds like there's some
potentially some discussion within the
committee that this may be amended in
which case
uh we would probably withdraw our uh
rejec
concerns but i just wanted to flag that
and certainly i'm happy to try to answer
um we'll absolutely have an amendment
for this bill and yes it will
representative abramson has a question
all right thank you uh mr chairman thank
you for taking my question
um what's uh do you recall what page in
line the
provision says that they are allowed to
have unlimited number of
well it doesn't specifically say
unlimited but there's no restriction on
it either it doesn't
say anywhere that there is a limit to it
so
i think by extension and i'm again i'm
no attorney so i would certainly defer
to an attorney
but i my understanding would be that uh
there would be no restriction on it
just it's the word there's a plural word
it says outlets
and that having a plural s implies more
for the question may inquire um
and what do you think would be a
reasonable limit for this particular
bill
uh again i think our understanding when
they first came when this bill first
came forward
um that the intent was to have one per
brewery which okay we could live with
that
so if you're a brewery in say lincoln
new hampshire maybe you have a location
in portsmouth or whatever
uh the example used earlier but
ultimately the way it's currently
drafted you could have one in portsmouth
one in manchester one in nashua one in
concord
essentially and this would apply for
every single brewery so now we could
have a situation where
we could have a beer bar in every corner
competing with you know the legitimate
okay all right thank you very much
for your testimony thank you i can
assure your concerns will be addressed
okay and let's see who else uh let's see
another
here
hi can you hear me okay yes good morning
good morning
chairman hunt and members of the
committee for the record my name is
scott shire and i'm the director of the
new hampshire beer distributors
association
and uh we're neutral on this right now
um as presented we're generally
supportive of the bill
anything that advances the goals of our
new hampshire brewer partners and the
industry in general
especially sort of mirroring that
on-premise on brewery experience that
people can
can have in neighboring states of maine
or vermont or massachusetts
is generally good like uh like mike
summers and
and some of the others we do have some
concerns with the satellite location
or locations um and also the production
requirement but
as it stands right now we're supportive
of of the bill
and uh eager to work with the committee
on on any amendments that are
coming forward so uh i'd open up the
questions too and uh and thanks for your
attention
representative abramson has a question
yeah uh thank you very much for taking
my question
uh basically the same question did you
need just one satellite location or
do you have uh some businesses that
would need some breweries that would
need
you know more than that they need two
for example just
seasonal or what have you yeah i think
thanks for the question
um generally speaking i think one is
probably a reasonable amount
um you know given the size of our our
geography or size of our state
that probably would suffice and i think
so obviously one was what we did with uh
the wine the wine producer
and the argument somewhat is that um
you're if you where you're manufacturing
uh zoning is such that it you might not
really lend itself to being a retail
type location where people come in and
take something in and so the idea
one is that you could divide your
business in the sense that you would
have a
a manufacturing facility that's in a
manufactured zoning or you don't think
that's
you know warehouse type environment but
that if you wanted to have
your actual retail arrangement to be in
a place that is
more conducive for consumers
okay um thank you
thank you scott and let's see
uh dennis molnar molnar
and uh is dennis on
are you done oh there you are okay all
and
and still good morning
can you hear me yes we can hi everyone
uh thanks for your time this morning
my name is dennis molnar and i'm the
co-owner with my wife of concord craft
brewing company
um on a normal year in normal session
we're just a few blocks away from where
you folks regularly meet
um and i just think
that uh part of my testimony um really
relates to
kind of the adventures we've had over
the last year or so with kovid
um i'll say i am in support of the bill
and the various provisions
including um one satellite for
uh for all breweries of of any size
and i think our experiences over covid
really showed that
um having the ability to um
optimize and uh react to
these kinds of challenges really was
very important for our business
right before covid hit we were in
discussions with the liquor commission
it looks like
at least at least a year ago that we
were the largest producing
nano brewery in the state we produced
about 1800 barrels in 2019
and even last year and so we've been in
discussions with the state to move to
a beverage manufacturer and so
a bill that better aligns some of the
different rules and regulations for
moving from um i think as it was said an
innovator or
um um a brewery to
to one that's a larger business would be
very helpful to us
um but when kovid did hit we were in dis
we we have two distribution partners
in the state so we certainly use and
take advantage of
the three-tier system and when kovitt
hit
um we were distributing to about 300
different retail outlets in about 200
different restaurants and bars
various uh of our products and
uh the day after cove it hit um the
distribution went down to about zero
and um for about two months uh in
addition to taking back
uh kegs of draft beer from uh
restaurants and bars throughout the
state
uh we did expand um our ability to sell
from our tasting room in in downtown
concord
and opened up delivery um and for
several months we sold more from our
tasting room than we did the 500
outlets that we had previously sold uh
our products through
and the ability to ship within the state
the ability to sell more than one case
and the ability to have a second
satellite location that doesn't require
the hundreds of thousands of investment
in order to make quality
production would really be helpful for
businesses like ours that are trying to
move from being
a small family business to a business
that's a little bit more sustainable
throughout the state we employ four
full-time employees and 12
part-time employees and uh things go
well this year will produce about
uh 500 000 um pints of beer
and um just these changes in this
particular bill would really help other
companies who are trying to make the
transition from a little local
brewery to a statewide business
including through the three-tier system
and of distribution
i think it would really help other other
folks to do exactly what we've done
so big supporter of the bill and hope
you'll take that into consideration
great thank you very much for your
testimony is there any questions from
committee members okay
saying none and last but not least
uh keith fry who is in
opposition to the bill good morning
members of the committee
um ignore the ring phone in the
background of course that happens as
soon as i get online
um i just wanted to um for the record my
name was kate fry from new futures
um and you know we we have
found this bill very confusing from the
beginning
we don't have any issues necessarily
with
um you know making nano breweries more
competitive
certainly getting rid of the requirement
of what can be sold
but um i have to go back to what
representative van hooten said
is that we are slowly um dismantling the
three-tier system with every little move
like this and it it is concerning
um i'm happy to hear that there'll be a
hundred to 150 million dollars in
additional revenue with each satellite
location
but maybe we should take a look at that
as well and
none of this funding um proportionately
goes to
uh treatment recovery prevention of
substance use disorder so
it's great we're increasing revenues for
it but where is that going as far as
helping the people who are suffering
from
substance use disorder um i agree as
well that
um with mike summers and um being more
as far as the concern about the retail
outlets
um and i do have a big concern about
expanding the interest date
um delivery for um but it sounds like
basically
all vendors um and would want to have
more information about that
so you know in this time where we're on
a committee hearing and we're here
there's going to be
immediately here there's going to be an
amendment a and yet
people really don't have access to
getting that amendment right away
um i would strongly suggest the
committee retain the bill
um i think there are some good pieces in
here but i just feel like
um this has been a moving target this
particular bill from the beginning
first it was going to get rid of the
food that it had something to do with
the food requirement then it didn't and
so it's just been really difficult to
follow
um i appreciate the committee's time and
um
again i would encourage committee
looking at retaining this bill
thank you great
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions from the committee
seeing none um so just when i got
through my list i didn't see their
two hands popped up so um and
and now we have three hands pop up no
maybe not okay uh so
uh i will call on andy day
and still good morning i mean
here we go sorry about that um
good morning um chairman hunt and
committee members um thank you all for
being here today
my name is andy day uh i own daydreaming
brewing company
uh meadow vineyards duare distilling uh
and a small restaurant cask and vine
located in downtown derry
uh i am in strong support of sb 125.
in this past week my partner and i have
secured just under 100 000
in investments to grow all three of
these businesses simultaneously
um and this is through personal loans
with citizens in the dairy community
uh a significant part of our business
plan moving forward
uh was focused on the idea that having a
satellite tasting room
my current tasting room is 14 by 10 feet
uh so certainly not a lot of guests can
fit here
the proposed property that we have in
mind is three times that with three
acres of land
so this obviously would allow us to uh
provide a much richer experience
uh to our guests uh as well as
potentially grow the business ten times
over
uh given that the laws allow us um as a
winery to have a satellite tasting room
it seems only fair that breweries have
the same
my brewery is currently a one barrel
brew house which is 30 gallons at a time
more or less
it's nano in size this expansion and
growth will allow us to triple
production
with the addition of a satellite tasting
room uh
we'd be able to grow in a way that we
otherwise couldn't um so i i would very
much
um like to encourage and and uh in
support of sb125
thank you great thank you
any questions to the committee members
seeing them thank you very much
uh drew klein i
recently
you there drew yeah i had to unmute
sorry for that um
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify i am
uh drew klein i'm president of the
josiah bartlett center for public policy
and i just wanted to give you our take
on the effect of
125 as we see it
excuse me in our view the laws that
regulate new hampshire craft breweries
ought to facilitate innovation
creativity experimentation and
economic growth if they're too rigid to
do that then the laws inevitably will
make it harder for entrepreneurs to
scale up their small businesses
or possibly even keep them alive looking
at sb 125
we believe that it does make some
changes that will ease the regulatory
burden on these local businesses in ways
that will make it easier for them to
thrive
expand and make an even greater
contribution to the state's economy
we see four major changes in the law and
i'll just real quickly run through them
one sp 125 removes an entirely
unnecessary
and economically dubious prohibition on
selling more than a single k
or 12 pack to a member of the general
public that existing prohibition simply
forces people to buy beer for social
gatherings
say you're going to have a wedding or a
backyard lawn party or something in the
summer
it forces you to go to grocers or other
retailers rather than to craft brewers
to do that
it doesn't protect the public at all it
just shifts sales to other providers
typically to the out-of-state beer
producers that dominate supermarket
shelves
number two sb 2125 removes an
unnecessary prohibition on contract
brewing that again does nothing to
protect the public
but which restricts nanobrewers and
brewpub's ability to provide additional
supply to meet growing demand
or to reach markets elsewhere in the
state
the bill removes an unnecessary
prohibition on
interstate shipping of alcoholic
beverages directly to consumers
all that existing prohibition does is
force consumers to order from other
sources
whether supermarkets or out-of-state
suppliers by making it illegal for them
to order
the same types of beverages directly
from in-state producers
this prohibition again gives large
out-of-state breweries and wineries a
competitive advantage over
new hampshire businesses removing it
would let new hampshire businesses offer
a delivery service
that consumers want and that's become
increasingly important as large segments
of the population
and economy have made permanent shifts
to remote work
so with fewer people commuting to an
office
demand for delivery has increased and
it's likely to remain strong
permanently it's unclear why the law
should let consumers order beer and wine
from supermarkets or from out-of-state
suppliers but prohibit them from
ordering beer and wine directly from new
hampshire businesses
and last sb-125 removes a prohibition of
breweries
creating a retail location separate from
the brewing facility itself
this bro this prohibition excuse me
again puts new hampshire breweries at a
competitive disadvantage
there's no harm to the public and
letting a brewery establish a satellite
retail location separate from the
brewing facility
but because the state's population is so
heavily skewed to the south
we look at this and believe that ending
this prohibition would be a particular
help to the many brewers that are
located in the merrimack valley and
above
so grocers as you probably everybody on
this committee knows
have very limited shelf space it's very
challenging for small breweries to
convince supermarkets to carry their
products
as an example one of my favorite
breweries is schilling
up in um the north country and uh
they're not
carried at any of my local supermarkets
um
and but they're an hour and 45 minutes
away from my house so if they were able
to
to have a satellite location in the
southern part of the state it'd be much
easier for me
to go get their products and again it's
no
no threat or harm to the public i'm not
sure
why the provision there as i read it
does not include nano breweries or brew
pubs i'd just like to flag that to the
committee
the ability to open a separate retail
location could be even more important
to these smaller brewers it's easier
than ever now
for small brewer to find affordable
retail space in places like manchester
nashua and the seacoast
being prohibited from opening such a
space is an artificial constraint
that really only hurts small businesses
that are trying to grow
with commercial real estate now prices
being really low
it's totally reasonable to believe that
a nano brewery or a brewpub
could easily find an affordable retail
space
in a separate part of the state that
would allow them to reach a new market
it's not clear why the law wouldn't
include them as well
in some we believe that sb25 would have
the effect of removing unneeded barriers
to small business growth
reducing some of the advantages that
large out-of-state brewers have over new
hampshire craft brewers right now
and increasing competition among brewers
which would be good for them
and good for consumers and one last
point
and i think this is important for
members of committee to think about
though craft brewing has exploded in the
past few decades
beer consumption in the u.s has actually
declined slightly
in the last decade in other words the
number of beer consumers
is not really growing it's actually
slightly shrinking
so the changes included in sb-125
would not increase alcohol consumption
they instead would free new hampshire
brewers to compete on a more level
playing field
for the limited number of beer consumers
that do exist
and one last point on the
retail locations it's just again it's
it's not clear to me what the
protection to the public would be by
limiting
the retail locations to one per brewer
or
by prohibiting brewers from teaming up
and selling
their their wares together at a
particular retail location
the law really should be about
facilitating competition
and helping consumers and not protecting
one particular industry by
disadvantaging another
and uh happy to take questions if
anybody hasn't
uh evidently we do have questions
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh mr klein are you
representing
are you representing uh yourself today
no as i said in the beginning i'm here
for the josiah bartlett center for
public policy
okay thank you and representative
burroughs has a question
um yes thank you for taking my question
mr klein
um which is um these not being
not being um familiar with how the
industry works
um these craft brewers would you say
that these retail
um locations are a prime way for these
for these small
businesses to get word out about their
product given the difficulty
of getting them into supermarkets and
those types of retail outlets
yeah i think potentially that is true um
so
one way to think about this is that so
if you have a supermarket
if your market basket or hannaford or
shaw's or even one of the smaller
grocers
you obviously have limited shelf space
and you want to maximize the
um product going off the shelf right so
you want to have something that
consumers already know that's why you
sell
budweiser and the big name brands right
so
um if you're using some of that shelf
space for a totally unknown
nanobrewery you have to do a lot of your
own promotions so it's not it doesn't
make sense for you as the grocer
to um dedicate a lot of shelf space to
small breweries that customers don't
already know and that's one of the
reasons why it's so hard for a small
brewery to get that shelf space
so you've noticed i'm sure you guys have
the number of beer stores that have
opened up in new hampshire over the last
decade
those also have very limited shelf space
so
um so i think that's one of the reasons
why you would want to allow
these small breweries to open a
satellite location again as i mentioned
um commercial real estate rents have
dropped dramatically so
it's certainly not unreasonable to think
that a nano brewery
could open a retail location in the
southern part of the state if they're
located out west
or vice versa um you know if you're
located in the southern part of the
state a lot of good breweries in the
southern part of the state that might
want to open
a retail outlet in hanover for example
or littleton and compete with the
breweries up there um i think the law
should facilitate that kind of
competition and not put artificial
restraints in front of it because when
you do that
one of the things that you accomplish is
to just make it
harder for these small businesses to
scale up to hire more people
um and to grow their business and and i
don't think the law should be making it
harder for them to do that should be
making it easier for them to do that
thank you very much
okay uh is there anyone else
would like to speak on this issue i do
have another hand
no went up and then not someone might
want to see why not
and all i know is that you're a grocery
association it's just john dumas or
i saw you for a second oh there you are
all right great okay
hey july how are you great in yourself
one time
it has been it has been busy times with
the uh covert situation so
i apologize for not uh being in to see
you
all in person i miss that uh friendship
we have every year of meeting with the
legislators
however i am here today to testify on
this bill
and for the record uh my name is john
dumas i'm the president and ceo of the
new hampshire grocers association
the association is opposition is enough
as opposed to
senate bill 125 relatives of the
beverage manufacturer licenses
as currently written the nhga represents
over 900 members in the state
of new hampshire from the small
independent mom-and-pop establishments
to convenience stores to the large
change-operated
supermarkets and most of those have
off-premise licensees
our membership also includes numerous
categories of suppliers and
several craft beer and wine
manufacturers
who's close to 1 000 full and part-time
employees
we want to highlight our concerns with
the senate amendment
which we believe creates several
unintended consequences
and this is somewhat uh close to what
we've heard
recently by mr moore and uh
and others uh from the industry first in
section six
page four line 18 it would allow
beverage manufacturers to create retail
outlets
and off on-premise sales locations
separate from
manufacturing facilities as a concept
this would be similar to wineries which
are allowed
one retail outlet license
this language pluralizes outlets and
does not specify
each license would be only allowed one
retail outlet at minimum we believe this
section
should mirror what is in place in new
hampshire wineries
it shouldn't be any more lenient than
what they have
we are also concerned with section 5 of
the bill which adds
quote importer wholesaler or retailer
to list of organizations that can direct
ship alcohol to consumers
as a direct conflict with the three-tier
system
and that was brought up earlier you know
should we be protecting the three-tier
system
we are very adamant that we need to
protect that for the safety
of the state for the consumers and the
retailers
this could have been an unintended
influence corporations with large volume
buying capacity could create a system
where they could ship large volumes of
alcohol at lower prices
than local retailers this would add
pressure
to small local businesses who are
already balancing competitive pressures
we believe that a much more appropriate
way to handle direct shipping
would be to limit the shipping of two
manufacturers shipping their
own product this would allow consumers
access to increasing variety of products
not available at the local retailer
while maintaining the system
no one can argue the rapid increase in
popularity and number of craft beer
options
available to consumers as demand has
increased over the
last few years current methods of
distribution have continued to increase
the number of products widely available
throughout the state
maintaining the current three-tier
system is important
to ensuring consumer safety beverage
manufacturers and small brewing
facilities
have thrived under the current system
offering significant
consumer choice while enjoying
considerable flexibility
as the craft beer industry continues to
grow in size and complexity
it will be increasingly important to
maintain current checks and balances
that ensures quality and safety
standards across the state
we respectfully request that the bill be
amended to address
these concerns and look forward to
working with the committee
to make those changes happen and i'd be
happy to answer any questions anybody
may have
uh i see keith hammond's got his hand up
so i hope you will
uh upload your testimony uh to our
webpage so we all can glad to do that
great
questions from the committee members i
don't see any
is anybody else would like to testify on
senate bill 125
i don't see any more hands up uh and
it's 1209 so not too bad
given that we were an hour late or 10
minutes late uh
so for the committee members uh what i'm
thinking right now
is that yes i have been working on an
amendment because i knew these issues
were out there
and i have been looking at it and
reviewing it
my expectation is to send out that
amendment to
everyone and certainly if anybody in the
public would like to have a copy of them
just send me an email and i will
forward once i have once i have it done
it will try to address all these some of
these issues that have come up
um and i probably
um just for the sake of
forever i will probably next tuesday
will have a
hearing on the amendment so that no one
will ever say they didn't get a chance
to
weigh in on it so um so let's plan
for next tuesday we'll have a uh we'll
first we'll have a hearing on the
amendment to 125
and then um in terms of executing
starting new exec bills
um we're we're not under a lot of
pressure to exec bills at this point
um you know in terms of you know when we
have the time we have the you know
almost the whole month of may but i
wouldn't necessarily want to do that
but um as well i'll pick through and
see bills that i think that might be
easy to get started and i will of course
be
um talking uh to my minority leader
and letting her know what what we're
doing ahead of time and what we're what
we're what i
foresee going on um and theoretically
you'll you'll know
right away if we're going to exact
something because there has to be
um come within the calendar it would
have to be
um stated that we're executing a bill so
so there'll be no surprises there
um but other than that we appreciate you
yes i i don't like surprises
so uh other than that um is there any
other questions for the committee
members on
okay see none thank you all and uh enjoy
the
rest of the day take care bye bye
everyone